Незаконне вторгнення Константинопольського патріархату
на канонічну територію Російської православної церкви.
Такими мілітаристськими виразами рясніють заяви
Московського патріархату щодо надання
автокефалії Україні. На офіційному сайті РПЦ
це твердження навіть винесли в заголовок,
підбиваючи підсумки вересневого позачергового
засідання Священного Синоду РПЦ.
РПЦ на чолі з патріархом Кирилом та УПЦ МП,
предстоятелем якої є митрополит Онуфрій,
обурюються і називають дії Константинополя
антиканонічними та грубим порушенням церковного права.
У свою чергу Вселенський патріархат
провів дослідження не лише з грецькими, а й
із російськими вченими. Як свідчать
офіційні історичні документи, Київська митрополія,
як і вся сучасна Україна, ніколи не передавалася
Московському патріархату до його канонічної юрисдикції.
На думку багатьох істориків та релігієзнавців,
Москва просто перекрутила значення так званої
"Грамоти про передачу", виданої Константинополем
наприкінці 17 століття. У документі дослівно було
написано так: "нехай Свята Київська єпархія
буде підпорядкована Святійшому Патріяршому
престолу великого і Богом береженого міста
Москви, а саме: рукопокладати у ньому
Митрополита Київського, коли виникне така потреба".
Тобто це означає виключно дозвіл на проведення обряду:
патріарх Московський просто здобував право
висвятити митрополита Київського від імені
Вселенського Патріарха, і не більше. Це було
тимчасове рішення, ухвалене з міркувань економії,
стверджують дослідники.
Вселенський патріархат також визнає, що
зважаючи на історичні обставини, весь цей час
фактично замовчував порушення цього документа
Московським патріархатом. Крім того,
експерти вказують на те, що таким агресивним
роздмухуванням ситуації навколо української
автокефалії Москва сама собі копає яму.
У православному світі все частіше порушується
питання про канонічність самої
Російської православної церкви.
Адже РПЦ фактично є самопроголошеною.
Вона ніколи не отримувала томос про автокефалію.
У 16-му столітті Москва просто скористалася
історичними обставинами і після захоплення
османами Константинополя тиском домоглася, щоб
московському архієрею дозволили називатися
патріархом. Це право надали за певних умов, які
потім, знову ж таки, Москвою не виконувалися.
Крім того, релігієзнавці підрахували, що
понад 200 років, тобто більша половина історії
Московського патріархату, - це взагалі
безпатріарший період. Приміром,
у 18-му й 19-му столітті російською церквою
керував обер-прокурор, тобто державний чиновник.
І потім, уже під час Другої світової, Сталін дозволив
діяльність РПЦ і було обрано патріарха. Втім, церква
лише за формою нагадувала релігійну організацію,
залишаючись під жорстким контролем держави.
Таким чином дослідники стверджують, що
Константинопольський патріархат не передавав
Київську митрополію, на основі якої виникла
Українська церква, до канонічної території
Московського патріархату. Кілька століть тому
Москві було надано лише право хіротонії, тобто
поставлення у священнослужителі. Це було
зроблено тимчасово, зважаючи на складні
історичні обставини. Україна була і залишається
канонічною територією Вселенської Церкви,
тож надання автокефалії - в компетенції
Константинопольського патріархату.